My book is trying to puts facts and to put
history and to put data in one of the most
controversial issues in history, which is
the issue of inequality and unequal income
and wealth and you know this is an issue about
which people have been fighting for centuries
in particular during the twentieth century
with the very violent fight between capitalism and communism, et cetera.
Instead of looking at only
one country, I look at over twenty countries
in the world, and I look at wealth and not
only at income so I can look, you know, I
study the distribution of who owns what and
not only who earns what.
Societies of the past were really based on wealth in the sense that inequality was primarily inequality between
those who own wealth and those who only own
their labor. One of the economic law to the
extent that there are laws in economics is,
indeed, R bigger than G. So the rate of return
to capital tends to be bigger than the growth
rate. It means that whatever wealth was accumulated
in the past is now being recapitalized faster
than the growth rate of the economy, which
is also the growth rate of labor income. And
therefore basically you better start with
some initial wealth. You know, if you just
try to enter the game only with your labor
income, well this has to be a very high labor
income. Now, there is another type of society
and another type of model of inequality that
has been emerging particularly in the United
States over the past few decades where you
have a huge rise of the top labor income and
in particular the top compensation that managers
in large corporations are getting.
Now of course the problem is that if you are neither
a top manager nor a top inheritor
then you lose on both grounds. So the good news is
that about the future is that when we read
the past in this way we can see that, you
know, there are several possible futures.
You know, it’s not as if inequality has
to rise indefinitely or inequality will reduce naturally.
You know, there’s nothing natural
in the history of income and wealth distribution
and there’s nothing natural in the history
of economic facts more generally.
I think we need to reopen, you know, the black box
of inequality in our industrial societies
and to look you know in a very crude way at
what the market economy is able to do and
what the market economy is not able to do.
So the market economy is great at producing
new wealth, but sometimes it can be quite
bad at generating distribution of wealth that
is equitable in the long run. So you know
its great to have entrepreneurs, it’s great
to have new wealth being formed, but this
has to be compatible with the size of the
world economy. If the top of the distribution
is rising three or four times faster than
the world economy, if you have that during
the next fifty years basically all the wealth
will belong to a very small international
elite and basically there will be no wealth
middle class anymore, and there will be a
level of inequality which is simply not compatible
with our democratic and meritocratic values.